I think what we learned over the last
year and what the doc shows quite a bit
is that our relationship as brothers as
family comes first and in the band that
comes second the Jonas Brothers are
opening up like never before it wasn't
about money it's not about the fame it
was hey brothers you want to do
something awesome again together the
band's new Amazon Prime documentary just
dropped and gives fans an inside look at
the lives of Kevin Joe and Nick who went
through a contentious split in 2013
before reuniting earlier this year now
we're breaking down the 7 biggest
bombshells from the dock starting with
this nick says he felt love for the
first time with his ex Miley Cyrus the
two met after the boys were offered a
guest spot on a 2007 episode of Hannah
Montana he met Miley I think that kids
had exploded I started writing about
love and actually knew what it felt like
you know well first time I was asking
them the kinds of questions that only a
younger brother can ask their older
brothers bombshell number two Jo was
initially the only brother offered a
role in the 2008 Disney flick Camp Rock
their parents considered the offer but
ultimately decided not to split the guys
up my dad called dad president of Disney
Channel I said what if instead of just
Joe it was a band now remember those
purity ring's
yeah they talked about that to all the
kids that I grew up were doing it so I
was like oh this is cool probably been
like 15 I was like what is this
[Music]
and that was not who we were like it was
just something that we did we were young
kids but we wore the Rings through the
first bit of the band starting to
explode at that point it was ready too
late because it was in the media on to
number four they admit their biggest
regret as a band was signing on for
their Disney Channel show Jonas we
shouldn't have done that
it really stunted our growth you know I
feel like it was just a bad move yeah
like it was just not the time and and
literally we couldn't evolve because of
it it was no good
didn't feel like it was us anymore I
think that affected the perception of
the band that we were joke
next up Joe got emotional revealing he
was heartbroken when Nick decided to
break up the band I felt betrayed I felt
lied to I felt angry numb that was how
was heartbreaking what hurts the most is
that it came from Nick because he is my
best friend and I thought that he Kevin
and Nick we're gonna do this forever and
it was us against the world you know for
a while it was dark and guys he wasn't
kidding there was some seriously bad
blood between all the brothers following
the split especially after Joe and Nick
went on to perform with Al Kevin at
several Jingle Ball concerts in 2015 the
entire set has been singing all the
Jonas Brothers songs together
[Music]
all the big hits all the big moments and
I'm just not there I think that might
have been the hardest moment my entire
life
our final reveal all three of the guys
say that their time apart was necessary
for a successful return the time apart
was necessary and it led me to find
something even greater than I could ever
imagine
[Music]
love the impact of falling in love has
made me want to be a better man a better
person and ultimately made me a better
brother I focused on my family on being
the best husband and father I could be
each II caught up with Joe Nick and
Kevin on Monday at the premiere for the
documentary and they opened up about
their decision to get so candid I think
for us it was it was important to step
into this new chapter with a lot of
clarity about how we were gonna approach
it and that was being as honest as
possible with each other and with our
fans and maybe people that were not fans
as well which I think is very important
and this documentary hopefully will
bring some families back together that
perhaps have had some tough times it
took time but after you know the initial
shock of it all we led to a better
relationship and then this documentary
really shows the real come back together
moment I am living for the Jonas
Brothers 2.0 and of course et will be
here to keep you in the know on all
things Nick Kevin and Joe so be sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]